anfang august geht in den ersten
bundesländern der schulbetrieb wieder
los doch haben die länder die
hausaufgaben hinsichtlich corona gemacht
für bundesbildungsministerin anja
karliczek ist klar der idealfall wäre
der regelbetrieb in der schule
doch die kultusminister der länder
richten sich auf drei varianten ein das
eine ist eben regelbetrieb mit hygiene
konzept das zweite ist ein hybrides
schulmodell wo ein teil der kinder vor
ort unterrichtet wird im
präsenzunterricht andere eben digital
und die dritte variante ist die wenn das
infektionsgeschehen hoch ist wenn wieder
irgendwo ein ausbruch ist das mal
vielleicht auch kurzzeitig noch einmal
zum homeschooling zurückkehren kann
das erneute mögliche homeschooling setzt
allerdings voraus dass auch finanziell
schwächer gestellte schüler
entsprechende hardware zur verfügung
gestellt bekommt und wir haben gerade in
den letzten monaten viele unterstützung
auch von bundesseite gegeben das eine
ist das jetzt flächendeckend aus den
schulen heraus kinder mit endgeräten
ausgestattet werden können wenn sie von
zu hause keine endgeräte haben also
unterstützung für bedürftige das zweite
ist dass wir auch noch mal aus dem
digital packt heraus beschleunigungs
möglichkeiten gegeben haben dass man
vorab jetzt schon in schulen zum
beispiel wlan organisieren und
einrichten kann
auch wenn man das konzept noch nicht
abgeliefert hat dass man eben die
technischen details hat aber die
umsetzung muss vor ort in den ländern
passieren
die entwicklung eines impfstoffes gegen
des corona virus ist in vielen ländern
bereits fortgeschritten deswegen zeigt
sich die bundesbildungsministerin in
dieser hinsicht zuversichtlich
ich rechne damit dass wir bis mitte
nächsten jahr ist ein impfstoff für eine
breite bevölkerungsschicht zur verfügung
haben
wichtig ist aber dass wir uns immer im
klaren darüber sind dass es bei der
impfstoffentwicklung auch rückschritte
geben kann
es gibt formen von impfstoffen der kombi
zum ziel normalerweise dauert die
impfstoffentwicklung mehr als zehn jahre